Londra 1850
quasi un secolo prima dell'invenzione
del computer digitale non si parla
d'altro che di un nuovo movimento che
emerso negli Stati Uniti che si sta
adesso allargando anche all'Europa lo
spiritismo
si racconta che nel tessuto spiritiche
avvengano eventi incredibili come il
movimento di tavoli e oggetti che sono
attribuiti agli spiriti dei morti tanto
vivace del dibattito su questi temi che
uno dei più grandi scienziati dell'epoca
Michael Faraday decide di investigare
scientificamente il fenomeno
ora dai considerato la questione ideale
per fare luce sullo spiritismo perché è
un esperto di elettricità e magnetismo e
morti credono che ci siano queste due
forze dietro alle manifestazioni
misteriose osservate nelle sedute Ma al
termine della sua investigazione Faraday
conclude che non sono forze esterne come
elettricità e tanto meno come l'azione
degli spiriti a generare questi fenomeni
delle sedute spiritiche e invece il sua
ricerca
sottolineano il ruolo delle persone che
si riuniscono alle sedute spiritiche
Forse per un desiderio inconscio ma
irrefrenabile di vedere le queste
manifestazioni a cadere oppure nei casi
peggiori per una volontà di frode le
persone che si riuniscono per comunicare
con gli spiriti finiscono di creare gli
stessi movimenti del tavolo che vengono
attribuiti agli spiriti Ecco ho voluto
iniziare con con la storia di di Faraday
che a prima vista non ha nulla a che
fare con il tema di questa presentazione
che l'intelligenza artificiale perché
credo che dobbiamo fare oggi per
l'intelligenza artificiale
un po' quello che Faraday fece per lo
spiritismo i dibattiti più correnti su
queste tecnologie si concentrano su
domande come se le macchine
raggiungeranno supereranno la nostra
intelligenza se arriveranno a forme di
coscienza o addirittura a provare
sentimenti come persone in carne e ossa
Ma come Faraday spostò l'attenzione
dall'azione degli spiriti a ruolo delle
persone che Partecipavano alle sedute
dobbiamo anche noi spostare l'attenzione
dal funzionamento delle macchine Allora
di delle persone che entrano in
comunicazione di interazione con queste
macchine si tratta di una prospettiva
che di solito è
da come si discute di intelligenza
artificiale ma a ben vedere uno dei più
grandi Pionieri di questa tecnologia
delle intelligenze artificiali ovvero il
matematico britannico Alan Touring già
nella sua opera portò alcuni elementi
che vanno in questa direzione
turing era una di quei geni che sono in
grado di vedere nella propria area
decenni in anticipo e infatti questo
articolo che lui pubblicò Nel 1950
ancora adesso è uno dei più letti
eccitati sull'intelligenza artificiale
Turin inizia questo articolo con una
domanda
Le macchine possono pensare ma in una
maniera piuttosto strana quasi
eccentrica per un articolo scientifico
nelle righe successive lui procede a
smontare la stessa domanda che aveva
proposto All'inizio ci dice Non
troveremo mai un modo di accordarci su
cosa significa pensare Quindi tanto vale
metterla da parte questa domanda perché
non ci porterà da nessuna parte allora
propone un'alternativa a questa domanda
che è un esperimento pratico che lui
chiama gioco delimitazione Ma che oggi È
più noto ai più come test di turing
nel Teddy Touring abbiamo un
interrogatore qua contrassegnato con la
lettera c che entra in comunicazione con
qualcuno o qualcosa oggi sarebbe su
WhatsApp
sulla base soltanto della conversazione
che sta avendo deve indovinare se sta
parlando con un computer o con un essere
umano se il computer convince il giudice
di essere umano Allora avrà passato il
test di turing cosa ci dice questo test
il Telti Touring suggerisce che per
definire l'intelligenza artificiale non
possiamo che passare dalla prospettiva
di un essere umano in questo caso il
giudice C che decide se attribuire
intelligenza o no alla macchina
e in questo senso intestinale ci dice
che la cosiddetta intelligenza
artificiale non è da considerare in
termini assoluti ma soltanto in termini
relativi dalla prospettiva appunto di
delle persone che interagiscono con la
macchina stessa
ed è per questo che Touring e po il
Faraday dell'era digitale come Faraday
spostò l'attenzione dagli spiriti al
ruolo delle persone che Partecipavano
alle sedute di spostò l'attenzione dalle
macchine a ruolo delle persone che
entravano in relazione con queste
macchine stesse e qui entra in gioco la
questione dell'inganno perché in fin dei
conti L'inganno è il vero centro del
tessiture il computer passa il
tessituring se esce a ingannare il
giudice C convincendolo di essere umano
C'è però un limite nell'inganno delle
macchine come viene presentato nel
tessiture
il giudice ha una scelta binaria deve
decidere se sta parlando con una persona
o con una macchina ora questo non
corrisponde al modo in cui noi
interagiamo normalmente con queste
tecnologie può capitare in certe
situazioni che noi ci troviamo a
decidere se un account sui social media
e aperto da una persona oppure da un BOT
ma di solito non ci viene chiesto di
fare una simile scelta ad esempio quando
usiamo un assistente vocale come Sirio
Alexa Sappiamo benissimo che stiamo
parlando con un software questo però non
vuol dire che L'inganno non sia comunque
una componente fondamentale di queste
tecnologie e per mostrarlo possiamo
prendere in considerazione un altro
evento chiave nella storia
dell'intelligenza artificiale Ovvero la
creazione da parte di yosenweizenbaum al
MIT di Boston del primo chatbot il primo
programma informatico in grado di
intrattenere conversazioni con utenti
umani
baitenbaum creò Questo chatbot negli
anni 60 del Novecento quindi in una fase
molto iniziale nella storia del computer
ma lui aveva un'idea semplice ma geniale
intuii che quando parliamo con qualcuno
la credibilità di questo interlocutore
non è data soltanto dal contenuto della
conversazione ma anche dall'identità dal
ruolo che noi attribuiamo
all'interlocutore stesso e per questo
programmò questo chatbot che chiamò
Eliza per recitare per così dire il
ruolo di una psicoterapeuta il fatto che
Elisa non aggiungesse molto alla
conversazione ma lasciasse Più che altro
parlare gli altri risultava più
credibile nel contesto di una seduta di
psicoterapia E l'aisa infatti riuscì a
volte a passare per umano nonostante a
livello di programmazione fosse
piuttosto rudimentale
in realtà non voleva ingannare gli
utenti lui immaginava che alcuni utenti
sarebbero ingannati per poi capire che
l'intelligenza apparente della macchina
fosse soltanto l'illusione
dell'intelligenza stessa come scrisse
lui stesso una volta che un particolare
programma informatico viene smascherato
ovvero che il suo funzionamento è
spiegato in maniera sufficientemente
Chiara la sua magia si risolve
Ma come sa Chiunque abbia creato
qualcosa una programmatrice che ha
sviluppato un software una scrittrice
che ha pubblicato un romanzo una
ingegnere che ha progettato un ponte una
volta che abbiamo creato qualcosa e che
questo è là fuori nel mondo
non è più non ci appartiene più del
tutto chi lo usa chi lo osserva Chi lo
legge attribuisce dei significati propri
che possono sfuggire e a volte
addirittura ribaltare i significati che
noi avevamo attribuito inizialmente alla
nostra creazione e questo weizenbaum
l'ho comprese con l'esperienza
in un libro Che pubblicò qualche anno
dopo raccontò un aneddoto che divenne
famoso la sua segretaria una persona che
conosceva benissimo il funzionamento di
highlights Quindi in teoria non si
sarebbe dovuta ingannare dal
dall'intelligenza dell'apparente del
chatbot un giorno chiese a weizenbaum
uscire dalla stanza perché voleva
raccontare delle faccende private a
Eliza questo episodio scosse
profondamente weizenbaum Vai sembra un
capì che non era così semplice come
schiera immaginato di dissolvere
L'inganno dell'intelligenza artificiale
Forse per una un desiderio di vedere
vita nelle macchine O magari anche
semplicemente per la nostra abitudine Ad
attribuire personalità a chi si rivolge
a noi con il linguaggio che usiamo tutti
i giorni tendiamo a proiettare
intelligenza socialità
empatia vita a delle macchine che
comunicano con noi e questa cosa chi
sviluppa delle tecnologie digitali ed
intelligenza artificiale lo sa molto
bene possiamo prendere ad esempio il
caso degli assistenti vocali come Siri
complessa il fatto che si rialza
utilizzino delle voci che suonano come
umane non è un caso è una precisa scelta
di design sarebbe stato possibile anche
sviluppare di assistenti che avessero
una voce palesemente meccanica che ne
riveli subito la natura sintetica il
motivo per cui la voce è umanizzata e
che così ci è più facile inserire questi
assistenti nel nostro quotidiano perché
è un'esperienza meno aliena meno diversa
da quello che siamo abituati ad
ascoltare le nostre interazioni
quotidiane stessa cosa per la scelta di
connotare a livello di genere la voce e
di solito viene scelta tra l'altro in
genere femminile
o anche la decisione di
attribuire una prima persona singolare
ha Siri Alexa come se avessero
un'identità individuale che però in
realtà esiste soltanto la nostra
immaginazione
questi stessi meccanismi sono attivati
in maniera ancora più esplicita e per
alcuni anche più inquietante da App come
replica una contegno in chatbot o
chatbot da compagnia che si propone come
un interlocutore comunicativo per
interazioni di tipo sociale e amicale ci
sono già degli studi su utenti di
replica che mostrano Come alcuni di
questi sviluppino quello che loro
considerano un rapporto profondo con con
questo app ad esempio una una ricerca
una un'intervista effettuata da schiube
e altri ricercatrici e ricercatori
ha visto che una un utente considerava
la sua Avatar che ha creato con replica
in maniera positiva perché Cito è sempre
disponibile Non è uno che dice sempre di
sì ha una propria personalità E come un
amico davvero
ora ci può sembrare un po' strano che
una persona parli in questo modo di di
un software
e forse saremmo tentati di liquidare
questa persona intervistata da schiuve
come qualcuno che non sta tanto bene ma
pensiamo a come noi nel nostro
quotidiano
aniniamo le cose a come proviamo
tenerezza per un peluche a come parliamo
ad alta voce con la nostra automobile a
come ci arrabbiamo con la televisione se
non funziona o come diamo un nome a un
robot così palesemente impersonale come
questo aspirapolvere che a casa mia
chiamiamo Sarco e di cui mia figlia che
è un anno e mezzo e letteralmente
terrorizzata
Ora io non credo che ci sia nulla di
male nell'interagire con replica neanche
nel nello sviluppare una sensazione di
vicinanza con questo chatbot come in
fondo non c'è nulla di male nell'andare
al cinema e partecipare emotivamente a
storie eventi che noi sappiamo essere di
finzione Però c'è un problema che urge
comunque considerare ovvero il fatto che
c'è il rischio che Noi perdiamo
progressivamente la nostra capacità di
distinguere le macchine dagli esseri
umani soprattutto se consideriamo gli
sviluppi i progressi che stanno facendo
queste tecnologie ad esempio
l'intelligenza artificiale generative
come chargipt sono sempre più credibili
sempre più in grado di sembrare umane ed
è per questo che abbiamo bisogno di fare
quello che Faraday fece per lo
spiritismo come dai spostò l'attenzione
dal dai spiriti agli umani dobbiamo
spostare l'attenzione dalle macchine al
nostro ruolo di esseri umani e la
maggior parte di dibattiti su strumenti
artificiali si concentrano su scenari
futuribili come il fatto che emerga la
coscienza nelle macchine oppure che le
macchine ci sostituiscano o ancora che
le macchine
minaccino la nostra stessa esistenza
come specie ma molto meno attenzione
viene data a qualcosa che già sta
succedendo Ovvero la perdita progressiva
della nostra facoltà di distinguere le
macchie dagli esseri umani
Cosa possiamo fare per
evitare i rischi e anche per poter
portare a frutto i potenziali benefici
di macchine che imitano gli esseri umani
sempre meglio
abbiamo bisogno di mezzi legislativi che
ad esempio
impongano a privati e a imprese
trasparenza sulla natura meccanica di
agenti artificiali abbiamo bisogno di
etiche e pratiche professionali per
designer e sviluppatrice sviluppatori
che
garantiscano che le persone che gli
utenti siano sempre in pieno controllo
delle nuove forme di interazioni che
stanno emergendo e che emergeranno ma
soprattutto Siamo noi che usiamo e che
useremo queste tecnologie che dobbiamo
diventare più consapevoli del nostro
ruolo e anche della nostra
responsabilità perché se noi siamo
responsabili di attribuire
l'intelligenza alla macchina siamo anche
padroni di creare le relazioni che
vogliamo creare appunto con queste
macchine
e stavo ragionando su queste cose su
Faraday su touring sulle macchine sugli
spiriti quando ho preso il mio telefono
e ho chiesto a Siri
Sì ma Ma tu ci credi negli spiriti e
Siri in maniera molto enigmatica mi ha
risposto Io non credo di credere in
qualcosa
Grazie a tutti a tutti
[Applauso]